is my shuttle discovery to the so for
today's is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before
on jisu back to you the international
space 20 years of continuous human
presence on the space station Thank You
marina not only are we on how we
accomplish that mission we're bringing
commercial partners we're fostering a
space economy so we're making sure that
we're always pushing forward always
taking that next step I think it's such
a privilege to be part of an
organization that recognizes if we're
not actually making steps and innovating
every single time we do this then we're
not truly answering humanity's called to
explore and to push those boundaries
Christina I know Bob and Doug are
veterans themselves but what advice do
you have for about a dub given your
experience as a long-duration station
crew member well being able to live
onboard the International Space Station
and work there is just such a privilege
you know you're a steward of this
amazing laboratory that's bringing so
many benefits down to earth and also
learning how we can push farther into
the universe so it
is quite an honor and I think that's the
main thing about how it feels to be up
there for a long duration you know in
terms of advice Bob and Doug have been
great mentors for me they've given me
advice for so many years it's strange to
be the one who could be in a position to
offer them anything but I would say that
as you know shuttle Flyers they used to
participate in missions that were really
really intense go go go all the time
long duration space flight is more of a
marathon than a sprint so I would tell
them to take that moment enjoy it and
you know really welcome the opportunity
to have part of your mission be taking
it all in and sharing that with the
people that got you there
thanks again Christina always a pleasure
to hear from you and fantastic words
thank you for sharing thank you and my
pleasure
so once again Bob and Doug once Bob and
Doug arrived at the station they'll be
greeted by astronaut kiss Chris Cassidy
but before we do that let's toss to a
briefing
hello everyone I'm astronaut Chris
Cassidy commander of expedition 63
onboard the International Space Station
flying 250 miles above the earth like
you I'm excited about today's launch and
the possibilities it will bring to
America into the world but also I'm very
excited that two close friends will be
arriving and joining the crew I had the
privilege of flying with Doug Hurley on
both of our first Shuttle missions back
in 2009 together we came to the
International Space Station and helped
construct the amazing facility that it
is today
although this will be my first mission
with Bob it was my honor to follow him
as the chief of the office when he left
back in 2015 to begin training for this
amazing mission personally I've been
very fortunate to fly a two different
spacecraft
launching from America on the shuttle
and most recently launching from
Kazakhstan in the Sawyer's but I can't
tell you how exciting it is to know that
we're once again launching Americans
from the coasts of Florida
and finally here's a story I'd like to
share with you back in 1981 John Young
and Bob Crippen lost on space shuttle
Columbia the very first space shuttle
flight marking the last time we flew
Americans on a brand-new vehicle
with them they flew an American flag
representing America's technical prowess
thirty years later that same flag was
flown to the International Space Station
this flag remains here today waiting for
Bob and Dunn
[Applause]
our flag means so many things to our
country and this small piece of America
represents what we'll be able to achieve
together we'll never stop exploring
and so Bob and Doug can take this very
special flag home to earth where it
awaits its next journey to the cosmos in
a few years it bursts Orion crew will
take this flag with it around the moon
all of this starts today I'll be
watching outside the window along with
everyone else in America and around the
world
I can't wait to look out the window and
see my friends on close approach
go Falcon 9 go dragon and go Bob and
Doug I'll see you soon and that was a
very special message from NASA astronaut
Chris Cassidy right now the lone
American aboard the International Space
Station so he will be ready and waiting
to welcome Bob and Doug when they arrive
tomorrow if liftoff happens today little
later tomorrow morning the countdown now
stands at t-minus one hour 25 minutes 54
seconds and counting until launch and
we'd like to share with you just how
much has happened here at Kennedy Space
Center since the last time we had a crew
on the pad launching from here as you
can imagine the end of the shuttle era
was a bittersweet moment for many people
across this spaceport but in the end we
knew we were striving for this day and
here we are joining us now is Kennedy
Space Center's deputy director Janet
Petro on the comeback we've seen across
Florida Space Coast
she's with Daryl nail now at OSB -
Darrell yeah Thank You Murray Janet you
were just telling me you were there at
the crew walkout tell me a little bit
about what you saw between the
astronauts and their families so very
historic it was very emotional
so when doug and bob first came out of
the doors you know of course cheer went
up from everybody you know the vice
president was there Elon was there the
crew families was there and of course
Bob myself and the rest of the center
leadership was there to cheer them on
but then you know when they came out and
then they went to the families and Bob
Jenkins said virtual hug and he shouted
out a virtual hug and he did this motion
and of course his his child also did
that virtual hug and I so I guess that's
the tradition of doing a virtual hug
with the families and then they you know
then they walked and got in the Tesla
either side and the family walked right
up to the window of the Tesla and we're
talking you know having a private last
moment with their with their father hand
on the wind I was very emotional I had
tears in my eyes I don't know how many
other people had tears in their eyes but
it was it was really a special emotional
and everybody was of course wishing them
well a lot of Allah I love yous a lot of
God speeds a lot of ad astra you know
take care all of that so it was very
special thank you so much for sharing
that with us and in in the context of
why it's so important Janet you remember
you've been here since 2007
yeah you were here in 2011 when shuttle
Atlantis came to wheelstop I've talked
to my uncle and father who worked out
here you know layoff notices went out
like the next day when the shuttle came
to a stop it was a very sad time Bob
Cabana
the director here called it depressing
tell me about that time and how far
we've come
yes so as you as you note it was the end
of a very iconic program you know a lot
of people had spent their entire career
working on the space shuttle program so
135 flights all of them launching from
launch complex 39 many from 39a where
we're gonna be launching from today and
then returning back you know what the
shuttle landing facility those two
iconic sonic booms was something that
all along the Space Coast people really
resonated with it really felt in their
hearts and look forward to so it was a
it was a very sad time but I will tell
you that 30-year program we had planned
for it the the workforce was incredible
you know there was there was a lot of
people who as I said spent their entire
career here and they wanted to safely
fly that shuttle out and then they
retired there was also another large
group of people that just wanted to put
on their resume that they had been
privileged to work on the Space Shuttle
so the the workforce I was incredibly
proud of because they were resilient
they were dedicated they were committed
to safely flying out that shuttle they
didn't skip any steps and regardless as
you said that they knew they were
getting their layoff notices I think it
landed on a Wednesday they were getting
their layoff notice on a Friday they
were in it till the end to make sure we
safely flew it out and of course we had
14,000 workers out here then
which we have a lot fewer here today and
of course our guest operations you
remember those last shuttle flights
everybody around the country wanted to
be a part of that experience and we at
the center really leaned forward to
maximize how many people we could get
both on-site and never mind how many
people were lined up at the beaches all
along the river to watch that last
flight and of course today with kovat
unfortunately we weren't able to have
any on-site guest operations which was
pretty sad for this extort flight but
I'll bet that there is a ton of people
watching from the beaches or from even
their TV as we launch here today sure
there is and tribute to your leadership
and Bob cabanas as well getting things
turned around here as a multi-user
spaceport getting the commercial
entities in here we appreciate all that
you've done to make that happen
Janet Petro appreciate you being here
Thank You Daryl all right Marie we'll
toss it back to you all right thanks
Daryl and as NASA and SpaceX have worked
for years to get to this moment
today's mission opens the door to an
entirely new era in human spaceflight
not only for astronauts but someday for
the general public as well from the
beginning it has been our mission at
SpaceX to help make humanitary Wow
humanity a multiplanetary species and
today's mission is an important step
towards that goal the key to opening up
space access for people like you and me
is reusability without it traveling to
space is just far too expensive for the
average person to do imagine how
expensive a flight from LA to New York
would be if you had to throw the plane
away after a single trip a lot exactly
that ticket would cost hundreds of
millions of dollars and almost no one
could ever afford to fly both a Dragon
spacecraft and the Falcon 9 rocket are
designed to be reusable which not only
improves the reliability of the vehicles
and that their flight proven again and
again but it also drives down cost this
is essential to enabling not just a
handful of people but rather hundreds of
thousands of people to get out there and
to explore the moon Mars Beyond and I
for one it is my dream to visit
Jupiter's ocean
Europa Leland you're one of the lucky
things that's had the opportunity to get
off the planet and go explore where
would you like to go next
you know Laura I think I would like to
go to Mars and you know be there if we
know a year about a year each way and
then a year on the Martian surface but
the one condition I would have to have
my pups would have to go with me because
it's about exploring new places but
taking your family with you you know we
have these crewmates that are people
that you get to know and love you know
over course of training but it's nothing
like having your family with you and I
think that's something that we're going
to be seeing in the future people living
and working on other planets as a family
a lot of people who want to see your
dogs we've seen them in an official
portrait I know that the dogs came in
with you know take a picture in your
spacesuit and back in the day you know
no dogs allowed in NASA
[Laughter]
well they had their moment they sure did
and knowing that the opportunity to fly
to space as a private citizen or a
private dog maybe one day is right
around the corner we have a new poll
question on Twitter for you so if you're
given the opportunity would you travel
to space let us know and we'll share the
results a little bit later right well
there is not a lot of cargo engineering
technical ball for I'll just keep
farming in propellent with
all right now while there's not a lot of
cargo in today's mission dragon is
carrying two special payloads aside from
Bob and Doug of course the first is a
series of custom art pieces entitled
humankind by Los Angeles artist Tristan
Eaton these indestructible double-sided
paintings are made from gold brass and
aluminum and they celebrate how far
humanity has come as well as how far we
still have to go it includes a beautiful
homage to the Saturn 5 rocket as well as
a nod to Bob and Doug's current ride to
space you can find more images and
information about these pieces on
SpaceX's social channels next in the
spirit of inspiring the next generation
of explorers we wanted to celebrate the
class of 2020 from kindergarten all the
way through graduate school SpaceX and
NASA invited students from around the
world to submit their photo to fly on
America's first human spaceflight in
nearly a decade
each graduates photo was used to create
a mosaic image of the planet Earth which
we printed and is being flown aboard Bob
and Doug's flight on the crew Dragon
spacecraft we received nearly 100,000
photos so thank you and congratulations
to all the world's graduates I am so
proud of what we're doing today and I
think about regular people fly in space
on a SpaceX rocket one day when I first
went to space I thought my primary task
of installing the Columbus laboratory
would be my aha moment but it was when
Peggy Whitson invited us over to the
Russian segment to have a meal she said
you guys bring the rehydrated vegetables
we'll have the meat and we you know
we're doing this having this meal and
it's with African American Asian
American French German Russian the first
female commander breaking bread at
17,500 miles an hour going around the
planet every 90 minutes and when I think
of that perspective shift that I got
looking out the window flying over my
hometown flying over Leo's hometown in
Paris flying over URIs hometown in
Russia it brought us all together as a
civilization and I think that's what
spaceflight does for us the more people
that have the opportunity to go to space
will feel like it's a it's an
international
of people working together for the good
of humanity and all humankind absolutely
and it's exactly what that piece of art
was all about yeah
and following today's mission we will be
one step closer to a future where we can
all have that experience we can all have
that orbital perspective and the ability
to explore new worlds in just over an
hour from now Bob and Doug will be the
first people to launch on an American
vehicle in almost a decade for the team
at SpaceX it's really hard to put into
words how honored we feel about the
trust that Bob Doug and NASA have put
into our team to carry out this critical
mission I worked on crew dragon for for
two years and I can just imagine what
all of my friends and colleagues are
thinking right now as they sit in
anticipation and excitement for what's
to come
absolutely and speaking of those who
have carried the hopes and dreams of
science and exploration we have a few
shoutouts to share with you from some
big fans of NASA and SpaceX Wow we're
making history again the NASA program I
am there with you guys in spirit
Bob good luck I know you'll be fine I'll
be watching and got everything crossed
arms legs
I'm tighten or not can't wait for you to
get back safely this is the first time a
u.s. built rocket has taken people into
space in nine years is quite an
accomplishment so for us at the
Planetary Society more rockets means
more exploration more people in space
means more exploration more countries
involved in the endeavor of space flight
means more exploration this is how we
know the cosmos and our place within it
so congratulations SpaceX here's wishing
your team and the crew especially a safe
journey and the joy of discovery let's
go and a big thanks to William Shatner
and Bill Nye for those well wishes and
while we're keeping an eye on the pad we
want to bring in NASA astronaut Rex
Walheim
if that name rings a bell it's because
he flew three
shuttle missions to the International
Space Station including the final one by
Atlantis sts-135 he was one of the last
four people to ascend the tower at pad
39a and head to space and he currently
is deputy director of safety and mission
assurance at Johnson Space Center in
Houston Rex Walheim thanks for joining
us you and leland actually flew together
hey Rex Rex you flew on the final
shuttle mission we said sts-135 with
Doug in fact what's it like seeing him
in crew Dragon right now it's great this
is what we've been looking forward to
you know after the end of the shuttle
program you know it was a very important
time we wanted to transition to this
commercialization of spaceflight to
allow these commercial companies to take
our astronauts to and from the space
station so in the nine years we've had
since we last landed on Atlantis we
really worked hard for that we worked
with our SpaceX partners and our Boeing
partners and here we are today is a day
we're taking that first step in this new
era what do you remember most about
launch day for sts-135 I think it was
just you you felt the the weight of it
this the Space Shuttle was a story
program 135 flights and thousands of
people had poured their lives into this
program to launch probes to the planets
to launch the Hubble Space Telescope and
then of course to build the
International Space Station so you knew
the incredible accomplishments of this
program and so you wanted to finish
strong and then when it finally became
launch day you'd finish the studying
you'd worked really hard and now it was
time to kind of soak it in and I think
that's what Bob and Doug are doing right
now they're sitting on the vehicle
talking to each other listen to the
sounds and feeling the vibrations as it
starts up and it's gonna be it's gonna
be a great great experience for them
hi Rex what is your take on private
astronauts going to space I think it's
great I think that the more we can do to
commercialize space to to make access
easier the better we are and I think
that's a part of this whole program you
get the cost down then more people can
afford it and you get the cost down you
can do more things in space more science
more research and
it is a transformative experience to fly
in space and I wish more people could
see that when you look at on the planet
like Lehmann was talking about earlier
with your crewmates from different
countries all around the world it gives
you a different perspective it gives you
a perspective that we're all crewmates
on this planet Earth and we kind of get
that now with the pandemic we understand
that we're all in this together and
that's what the space program does and I
want to see more people get a chance to
see the Earth from that vantage point
and I think it'll bring us all closer
together he wrecks a very serious
question here the worm or the meatball
Leland I saw you dissing the worm or how
can you do that the worm is awesome I'm
so glad to have an ass and worm insignia
back it's great all right well thank you
very much Rex we appreciate you and as
we watch the as we watch Bob and Doug
they're in the capsule we are an hour 10
minutes 57 seconds and Counting from
launch and we're going to send it over
to Hawthorne for an update Jesse thanks
Marie we're just an hour and 13 minutes
away
we're helped by our closeout engineers
to get into their seats attach their
suits to special umbilicals that provide
breathing air pressurized nitrox and a
communication link to Dragon systems
they conducted leak checks which for a
successful and communications checks
with the core here in Hawthorne which is
the person who will speak to them
directly throughout the entire mission
as well as the launch director in
Florida this is where they are checking
their comm pass through both ground
stations and trenton the tracking and
data relay satellites that we'll use to
talk to the crew the entire way to the
station
right and after those suit checks were
complete the closeout team was able to
seal up the hatch which also got its own
leak check and we confirmed that it was
good to go the closeout team at this one
has already departed the area around
their dad they're about twenty-five
minutes ahead of their schedule and
right now weather operators are kicking
off their final check on wind speeds at
the pad which are going to be used and
they're really important for that final
go/no-go for launch before we get to
that final go no-go various teams at
both NASA and SpaceX are going to do
some internal go
poles just making sure conditions are
good with Falcon nine to Dragon the crew
the range and the space station before
the final go is given so let's check
back in with Houston real quick for a
status in the team they're supporting
the spate in Mission Control Houston led
by flight director Zeb Scoville has been
pulled and we're go for launch
all systems onboard the station that are
required to be healthy for the mission
I'll report it good and we're standing
by station condition our board from the
International Space Station go Falcon
nine go dragon and Godspeed to Bob and
Doug all right thank you Gary if you are
just now joining us you picked a really
good time because we are one hour eight
minutes and Counting away from launch
this is our coverage for this mission
known as demonstration mission two or
demo two liftoff time still holding for
433 p.m. Eastern
tracking no issues with Falcon 9 or
dragon and we're still waiting for that
weather to hopefully cooperate we're
still tracking a few things like
precipitation and flight through clouds
we're hoping that clears within the next
20 minutes or so over the last three
hours our crew members Doug Hurley and
Bob Behnken donned their SpaceX suits in
the historic crew quarters suit up room
and made their way out to launch pad 39a
they walked out of the crew quarters
building just as every astronaut to fly
from this spaceport has done since
Apollo 7 they were transported to the
pad where the crew now on board the crew
Dragon spacecraft and we're continuing
to get views of them inside that cabin
live
des is a historic launch it will be the
first time a commercially built
spacecraft will launch people into orbit
and the US has sent people to the space
station from American soil since 2011
with the retirement of the space shuttle
program over the next hour we will
conduct a series of polls to get ready
for launch have Bob and Doug arm the
launch escape system and begin fueling
night launch is set for 4:30 3:00 p.m.
Eastern this will include a 12-minute
flight to orbit and then a 19-hour
flight to dock with the International
Space Station at 11:30 a.m. Eastern Time
tomorrow today's mission is the
culmination of years of work between the
teams at SpaceX and at NASA demo two is
going to be an end-to-end flight test
we're gonna start with launch today go
all the way to docking with the space
station and then when Bob and Doug come
home splashing down in the Atlantic and
this is gonna be the final test for NASA
to certify SpaceX for regular crew
flights to the space station and we've
been hearing a little from the crew
onboard dragon which is which they are
currently strapped into their seats as
you can see on your right screen they're
already through their seats or there
they've already been strapped into their
seats and through communications and
leak checks they're able to follow all
the milestones still ahead on those
displays just above them that you can
see there go ahead yeah we're gonna
equalize the pressures in the common
manifolds just to raise them a little
bit
so we will be momentarily cycling the
tank isolation valves I just wanted to
let you know for hours I just wanted to
take a pause to listen into the nets
okay we predict that day so they'll be
getting insight into all of the Dragon
and Falcon 9 systems as we proceed
towards launch at t-minus one hour and
seven minutes let's check in with John
in Sprecher for a status update on both
of those vehicles with the update John
well the good news is we've had a smooth
countdown this afternoon SpaceX team is
working no technical issues on either
the Falcon 9 or the Dragon spacecraft
for the Falcon 9 operators have
completely where they are actually still
in work they're going to complete a few
minutes propulsion checkouts
that are being done on both the first
and second stages the team will be
assessing their launch readiness with a
final go no-go Paul that will come at
t-minus 45 minutes and that will be
followed by propellant loading starting
at t-minus 35 minutes now earlier today
dragon operators performed a series of
checkouts of dragons flight systems the
spacecraft is also currently go for
launch our NASA Crew astronauts Doug
Hurley and Bob Behnken that you can see
inside the Dragon capsule on the right
hand side of the display they are
currently going through the various
screens simple checks their hatches
close suit leak checks are complete
contracts are good the next major event
for Dragon is going to be retract of the
crew access arm that you can see on the
left monitor up alongside the Dragon
capsule that's going to happen somewhere
between 45 and 42 minutes before liftoff
now the big one right now is the range
the range is currently red for launch
from historic pad 39a now the air in the
sea space is clear and the worldwide
network of ground stations as well as
the tracking and data relay satellites
they are ready to support dragon as it
heads into orbit but the range is red
for the weather we recently did clear we
went green for lightning but we are
still violating several constraints rain
accumulates
field Mills which is essentially you can
tell that the atmosphere is energized
around the launch site
we are expecting that will possibly
clear that we're gonna hear a weather
briefing at one hour with the
expectation that those conditions may
clear shortly afterwards and allow us to
move into propellant loading also we've
been releasing balloons what we're
seeing at the upper altitudes is
conditions look good for Falcon 9 with
Dragon no concerns have been expressed
by the GNC guidance team right now now
as a reminder today we have an
instantaneous launch window at 4:30 335
Eastern Daylight Saving Time or just
past 33 minutes after the upcoming hour
so we get one chance at it today but
currently t-minus one hour and three
minutes just passing that Falcon 9
dragon there are go the range is ready
to support but now we're waiting on the
weather is we've been expecting all
afternoon thanks John we've got an
extensive history now of flying Falcon 9
from the Florida coast and just last
year completed a test run of the mission
that were less than an hour from
beginning here today the purpose of that
mission was to demonstrate dragons
capability to safely and reliably fly to
and from the International Space Station
the success of demo1 was a really
exciting moment and it paved the way for
today's mission where we are just
moments away hopefully if we get that
weather from flying US astronauts from
US soil for the first time since 2011
dragon and Falcon 9 together have years
of operational experience or what we
refer to as flight heritage as I
mentioned earlier SpaceX has
successfully completed 21 flights of
Dragon to and from orbit since 2010
including 20 trips to the International
Space Station not only have we conducted
thousands of hours of testing we've also
enhanced and added a number of safety
features to Dragon
much of what was learned with the cargo
dragon was leveraged in design this man
cycling his complete expected behavior I
wanted to hear if you were able to hear
those
we actually did a we were just making a
comment about that heard some clicking
and and Bob watched it on the exit this
way though absolutely and that again
right there that's the crew talking to
the core here in Hawthorne California
who's going to be talking to them
throughout their a sent up held today so
they were just doing a quick check out
Bob and Doug confirm they were able to
hear it sounds like everything's still
good so still no issues with Falcon or
dragon back to what we were talking to
is we're describing these systems a lot
of what SpaceX did with cargo dragon has
been leveraged into this crew dragon the
vehicle is designed to be fully
autonomous which means it can basically
fly itself but it also features a full
manual override capability if the crew
needs to take control in case of
emergency many of the other enhancements
helped toward spacex has goal of
reusability and less refurbishment time
between missions so let's take a closer
look at some of these advancements
standing at almost 27 feet tall from
bottom of the trunk to top of the
nosecone crew dragons composed of two
main elements we have the capsule up top
which is designed to hold the crew and
any pressurized cargo and then an
unpressurized section known as the trunk
on the bottom and the nosecone at the
top of the capsule protects the docking
system as well as the guidance
navigation control system or what we
call GNC the nosecone opens for docking
and remains attached to the crew dragon
spacecraft unlike the previous version
of Dragon that and that helps towards
our reusability six we are at t-minus
one hour
Torgo for section 6 when ready we report
go for launch
I think dragon will put affection picton
work so the career just has a couple
checks and when they are ready for
launch we're gonna hear them report to
the core that they are go for launch
continuing to walk you through the
Dragon spacecraft opposite of that nose
cone is the trunk we can see it on the
left hand screen there where it's kind
of split right down the middle with the
left side black and the right side white
the trunk provides an attachment point
to Falcon 9 the Dragon capsule and can
carry any cargo uphill on the outside
one half of the trunk contains a
radiator that rejects heat from the
active thermal control system into space
using SpaceX's new pica tiling
technology the other half contains solar
cells that are used to charge the
spacecraft's batteries during flight and
you heard that call-out right there for
lunch the next up will be the go and
I'll go pull at t-minus 45 Bob and Don
or go for launch and again you're
hearing it alive from Metz this is
amazing very exciting the spacex is
designed the spacecraft is designed to
accommodate up to seven crew members
with modular seats that can be removed
and replaced by additional cargo the
seats are made of carbon fiber and will
be custom size for any crew members
flying onboard that control panel that's
centered between the pilot and Commander
seats consists of three touchscreen
displays and that just again allows the
crew to operate the vehicle and fly it
manually but also look at all of their
procedures relative position over the
earth the space station any alarms
alerts anything that they could possibly
want to do on draggin us through those
touch screens
and lastly our super Draco launch escape
system is a key safety feature of crew
dragon giving the crew the ability to
safely escape from the time of launch
all the way to orbit and that launch
escape system was put into work a little
bit earlier this year again on that
in-flight abort test as we look to the
future beyond this test flight the first
operational SpaceX prude mission for
NASA will be a little bit later this
year after Bob and Doug come home NASA
astronauts Mike Hopkins Victor Glover
and Shanna Walker and sweetie Noguchi of
the japan aerospace exploration agency
or JAXA were chosen to support this
mission being called crew one but today
Doug Hurley is the spacecraft commander
for this mission
he previously flew on to space shuttle
missions as the pilot will also go for
arming and watch the Cape system and the
on continent countdown net reporting
that technical pole was completed all
systems are proceeding we're monitoring
the weather as well debriefed we're also
looking at a watch item on a hydraulic
QD rod ring ring pressure will come up
at minus eight minutes and thirty
seconds and we'll be able to verify a
decay rate no concerns at this time
everything is reading nominal but
watching that item no other constraints
on Falcon are insensitive
Stage two our people bleed is complete
all right we just crossed the 55 minute
mark away from launch sitting right next
to Doug Hurley who's closest to your
screen is NASA astronaut Bob bankin he's
the net he is the Joint Operations
commander for demo2 and bankin
previously flew on to Space Shuttle
missions sts-123 and sts-130 and also
served a tour as chief of the astronaut
office so here's a little bit more about
the man who said testing out a brand new
spacecraft is an astronaut's jury
[Music]
when you go through the the launch date
preparations there's a lot of moments
that that kind of stand out to you one
is the kind of the celebratory piece of
it which is that you're walking out of
the suit-up room and getting in the
vehicle that's going to take you to the
launch pad when you close the hatch now
that's really when Doug and I are in the
vehicle and it's our vehicle and you
know we're really in control of the
mission at that point test pilots their
tasks prove that man could fly into
orbit around the earth and return live
and well to talk about it
there's always a a balance of managing
risk as you go forward to execute a test
point and figuring out a way to you know
collect the data we hear a sound okay is
that sound an expected sound or we see a
light is that light an expected light
what's the source of it is it sync up
with something else that's going on or
not
so trying to dissect all of that in real
time in your head is you know a lot of
things happen like that on on launching
up a vehicle from st. and Missouri
he is an Air Force colonel and flight
test engineer he flew aboard space
shuttle Endeavour twice introducing NASA
astronauts bankin my career at NASA has
kind of spanned a couple of decades at
this point I arrived with the class of
2000 went through the training program
primarily focused on the space shuttle
and the International Space Station
learning those systems having launched a
couple times on vehicles you know the
the second time was definitely different
than the first time you can feel a
little bit guilty of hey should I study
one more thing or one more piece of
information I should get am I really
prepared or not so that's definitely
different between where I was on my
first flight and where I'm at right now
it's been really interesting I think for
both my wife and I to have gone through
the process of seeing each other launch
in space I've seen her take that risk
and had it be in front of her and I've
done that to her there's just something
different about watching a rocket launch
when there are people onboard you feel a
little bit differently about the pit of
your stomach and I can only tell you
it's multiplied significantly when it's
somebody that you know and then somebody
of course that's a family member it's
even multiplied more for me personally
as a spouse watching everything that bob
has put into this over the last five
years the dedication that he's shown on
the perseverance is pretty special for
both of us though the way our minds work
it won't be until sort of the mission is
complete that you have really a chance
to savor it and celebrate it this is a
huge accomplishment for an Air Force
flight test engineer to be part of the
demonstration mission of a brand new
vehicle it's going to be amazing without
a partner that has that same
appreciation I think it can be
challenging for some folks there's a
there's a lot of work and a lot of time
that takes away from family that you
know that my spouse appreciates and I
love her for that really my role on the
demo2 mission is to make sure that we
get this vehicle tested and evaluated so
that we can move on to more operational
missions at the International Space
Station
we've got a lot of objectives onboard
the vehicle that we need to accomplish
to really make sure that it's good to go
well make sure all those systems are
working during the test flight so that
the future missions will have them
available even if they don't plan to
utilize them through years of the the
NASA team I'm helping to share that
experience and teaching them the lessons
that we've learned by going through this
now there's another capability in the
u.s. besides NASA to operate something
of this magnitude when is the last time
humans launched on a new vehicle
certainly on the American side it's been
several decades multiple vehicles under
development it's a great time from a
space exploration timeframe just to see
all that happening and it's because of
this nurturing of the environment being
able to pull in a wider group of people
who can contribute towards a human
spaceflight it's just it's a super cool
time on a deeply personal level I'm
really excited that my son is got to get
a chance to see me launch into space
being an astronaut has been a little bit
of an abstraction thing for him because
he's seen me do it in old videos but he
hasn't seen me do it for real and so I'm
excited for him to see this launch I
want to thank the entire Commercial Crew
program team that's worked together to
get to this point where we've got
vehicles in the launch bed ready to head
to the International Space Station
[Music]
we're just over forty nine and a half
minutes away from launch of the Falcon
nine caring dragon to the space station
right now the launch director and the
launch team are preparing for a
readiness for launch Paul in this poll
the 13 members of the launch team will
electronically indicate a go for launch
this is also the go for propellant load
now we're going to hear that in a couple
of minutes so while we wait we are
tracking you watching from all over the
country we're seeing large numbers of
you logging on or tuning in from
coast-to-coast as well as around the
world we want to know is this your first
time watching a launch live if not how
many of you seen before
tell us using the hashtag launch America
from your favorite social media website
as for me this isn't my first one I've
seen a lot but everyone is exciting now
coming up we're going to go into a
readiness poll as I mentioned currently
right now on other nuts the SpaceX
launch director is checking to verify
the dragon team is ready and that the
NASA launch management team is ready
they'll come back at about t-minus 47
minutes with instructions to the SpaceX
Falcon 9 team to make their final
assessments then they log into the
procedure it's a little different than
the old days where you hear a Go Go Go
you know position by position all up and
down the row in this electronic age
everybody just clicks on whether they're
go or no-go the launch director will
then at t-minus 45 minutes summarize the
end of the poll and will then provide
instructions for the team at the same
time we will begin getting ready for the
crew access arm retract and we'll show
you that on one of the screens that
we've got up
now currently we are continuing to
monitor the weather the weather is still
red it is improving we're looking at one
cell between the radar and the pad we're
keeping our fingers crossed that
conditions will improve but we're going
to be watching that for about another 15
minutes so it looks like we're going to
be good to begin propellant load once we
hear the polls but we still have to get
the final get the range green so that we
can actually do the launch in just 47
minutes from now let's listen to
countdown net for a moment
right now coming up on 46 minutes son
seconds before launch didn't hear any
significant chatter coming over
countdown one is lost rector to cut down
that pole is complete and we have a go
to proceed with propellant load lost
control proceed with swing in the career
our main car our move in 40 - 45 minutes
thank you lots of control
a reminder control room on hold and
launched gate protocol for not urgent
no-go conditions brief CER LD and it
will approve aborting the launch out of
sequence and perceive a launch abort for
urgent issues affecting the safety of
the operation operator shall call hold
hold hold on the countdown met launch
control will abort the launch other
sequence immediately and proceed into
the launch abort auto sequence operator
shall also advise the launch director
whether structural break up are fires
imminent or occurring her dragon manual
escape flight rules remainder of fire
alarm instructions here environment for
event of a fire alarm key operators
previously briefed or remain that's our
post while alarm is evaluated and have
at that personal safety is threatened we
will evacuate to the south phasing
emergency exit which leads directly
outside one final reminder
they'll be arming the launch escape
system momentarily need all personnel
please stay in your seats from now
through orbit insertion and dragon
separation from the second stage
reactive armor ejector started and
you've heard Mike Taylor the SpaceX
launch director give instructions to the
team we've also just heard the call the
crew access arm retract is underway
great view from the camera inside the
white room
as we see the arm moving away from the
Dragon capsule one of the major events
necessary to get down to t0 the next one
coming up we'll be arming of the escape
system on the Dragon capsule now right
now the next plan for Falcon 9 t-minus
35 minutes we will begin loading
propellant onto the first and second
stages now currently Falcon 9 is looking
good
dragons looking good the range continues
to be go for launch in terms of the
clearance around the launch pad both the
air and the sea space looking at the
flight corridor the ground stations the
NASA tracking and data relay satellites
are ready to support and we just
continue to monitor the weather our team
is getting constant updates we're
monitoring weather
Gaeta sensors around the launch site
looking to make sure that we can get
everything into the green position the
one that we're mostly looking at right
now is how much rain we're going to get
between now and liftoff whether it's
just going to be mild precipitation
that's within the rules for loading
propellant that's what the expectation
is but we're going to continue to watch
that so fingers crossed but right now
coming up at t-minus 43 minutes 18
seconds and counting
everything but the weather's go and the
weather is trending in the right
direction so we've got a fingers crossed
here
[Music]
at this time we're gonna send it back
over to Kennedy Space Center as the
action is picking up on the launch pad
thanks John I now that countdown clock
is continuing to tick and we are 42
minutes and 46 seconds away from launch
now as you just saw the crew arm
retracted that is the last major visual
milestone before liftoff and we should
be hearing out on the net soon's
confirmation that the launch escape
system is armed when that happens all
eight of the super Draco throttle off
valves are opened which means that those
engines can ignite okay so that means
those throughout those eight throttle
valves are opened and if those super
Drago's needed to fire in order for
Dragon to escape off of the pad they
could and so things running just a
little bit ahead of schedule right now
you'll bleed is complete
now we just saw the crew access arm or
track just a minute ago we saw NASA
astronauts Doug Hurley and newer visors
are closed and we're arming moment to
speak with them so we just heard the
astronauts confirm that they are about
to launch excuse me arm the launch
escape system that happens just before
fueling begins which we expect to happen
in just a couple of minutes we saw a Bob
and Doug suit up a little over three
hours ago then we watched them drive out
to launch complex 39a they were assisted
by the SpaceX ground team with crew
dragon ingress that happened a little
before two o'clock this afternoon and
then we saw the spacecraft hatch closed
and again just a minute ago we saw the
crew access arm retract we just heard
that the crew armed the launch escape
system and in just a few minutes we are
going to hear the call that they have
started propellant loading
launch escape system is verified armed
so we just heard that verification that
the launch escape system is armed or
switching to Gen 2
and we are going to send it over to
Hawthorne to take us through prop
loading Jesse from the parachutes to
launch escape system SpaceX has designed
crew dragon and Falcon 9 to be the
safest vehicle launch vehicle ever flown
and joining us today we have SpaceX as
Nick Picone who was our mission manager
for our in-flight abort mission earlier
this year and currently works on the
Starling team thanks for joining us Nick
hey Jesse I'm here at the launch and
landing recovery center with the
recovery team our dragon ground
operations team monitoring watch awesome
can you tell us more about the critical
safety features on this new version of
Dragon sure so dragon 2 was designed
with long-term reuse and reliability in
mind so fundamentally there are multiple
layers of redundancy to any of the
failure modes that we can conceive of
the NASA could conceive of when we were
working to design and test this vehicle
over the past few years but in the event
that we encounter an unprecedented or
multiple failures which push us outside
of our design space dragon also has
backup systems and operational controls
intended to keep Bob and Doug safe I'm
sure you've heard a lot about it today
but the launch escape system is primary
the primary backup system that we have
from the moment that the vehicle is here
on had being fuel all the way up until
orbital insertion at a high level the
launch escape system in the event of a
major falcon anomaly or emergency will
terminate a falcon thrust seperate
dragon from falcon and it'll use dragon
speed super Draco engines to quickly
pull the vehicle away from any kind of
Falcon anomaly now you talked a lot
about the launch escape system how
exactly is that activated is it
autonomous is it manually activated
definitely so for this system to work as
design you have to remember that the
vehicle could be flying it hundreds or
thousands of miles an hour through the
lower atmosphere so it's really
important that it's extremely fast and
highly reliable with very low chance of
false positives the launch escape system
fundamentally is set to look at a set of
pre-programmed criteria which are
onboard the view
dragon and Falcon are looking at higher
aid telemetry looking for a normal
vehicle dynamics loss of communication
between critical systems or manual
commanding our launch director and chief
engineer who you've heard a lot from
today are capable of sending a manual
command to Dragon to initiate a launch
escape and Bob and Doug are also always
able to to actuate the launch escape
handle and initiate a launch escape
themselves as well now that the system
is armed all of this is currently active
on the vehicle wow it sounds like
there's a lot that goes into it and we
did have an inflatable test earlier this
year to test this out can you tell us
what we learned from that test
definitely it was possibly the most
flight-like test of an orbital class
booster in history it was a fully flight
light test using a full Falcon 9 rocket
which we had to knowingly destroy in
order to get this fully integrated
system folks you didn't get a chance to
see it the vehicle followed normal crew
launch trajectory about a minute and a
half into flight
we had dragon autonomously trigger the
launch escape system based on a
reconfiguration of those triggers I
think perfectly we had we we continued
through flight had a successful
parachute deployment and splashdown and
then we did see Falcon rather
spectacularly blow up about 10 seconds
after separation it's important to
recognize that all of that happens from
command to actual separation of the
vehicle in under half a second
well yeah that sounds amazing thank you
so much Nick for joining us and talking
through those details with us enjoy the
launch today so we're gonna send it back
to KSC with Lauren Thank You Jessi we
are about a minute and a half away from
propellant load at t-minus 35 minutes we
should hear the call out on the nets
that propellant load has started so
that's about a minute and 13 seconds
away
hey Marie and Lauren I am getting goose
bumps over here it's just an exciting
moment when I was sitting in the vehicle
when we retracted everything when all
the loaded the problem was getting
loaded up I was just going through my
crew notebook I was thinking about you
know what my first step would be if
there was a malfunction because usually
everything goes nominally when you fly
to space but you have to think about the
things that you have to take care of you
know the first step you have to take
care of and my mission I was calling out
the abort calls like if we had lost an
engine where we go next when the
different abort calls around the country
and around the world so I think that's
what those guys are probably thinking
about now and just really getting ready
for this this mission to go go off
absolutely and we're just now about 20
seconds from when we expect propellant
loading to start again that's fueling of
the rocket all right we're getting close
we should hear that call out any second
now on the net so let's listen in
Mona has started fantastic
so prop load has started we've started
loading liquid oxygen on stage 1 and
stage 2 and y at liquid oxygen and our
p1 which is our rocky grade kerosene so
now that we are thirty four minutes and
42 seconds away from the first launch of
astronauts into orbit from American soil
since 2011 we know that the launch
escape system is armed which happened
just before fueling dragon prop load
happened weeks ago actually just a few
months miles down the road of what we
call Dragon land and those propellants
which are nmh or monomethylhydrazine
that's our fuel and nto or nitrogen
tetroxide that's our oxidizer those not
only feed the draco engines that propel
dragon on orbit but they also supply
those eight super aged super Draco
engines of the launch escape system so I
have one right here a little model Oh
doesn't come off the stand very nice so
as you can see dragon is actually broken
up into four quads and each quad has two
of the super Draco engines for a total
of eight of them and as I mentioned they
are by prop engines they have mmh and
nto is their oxidizer
now most abort systems from past space
vehicles I believe like Soyuz mercury
Apollo they all had an appointee escape
tower on top where there was essentially
like a mini rocket engine or series of
rocket engines on top and if they
weren't used those that that escape
tower would have to jettison itself from
the vehicle if it was used it would be
used to lift the vehicle off of the
rocket
well dragon is a little bit different in
that it's escape system it's actually
integrated into the vehicle and that's
great for a couple of reasons one one
less thing you have to jettison on a
nominal flight and so they're pretty
dormant just those throttle valves open
unless they're used and hopefully they
never have to be and yeah I mean the
other thing that that offers you is the
ability to escape from the pad all the
way to orbit because if you jettisoned
your escape system prior to that
you couldn't so yeah that's that's a
little dragon there yeah you era much
safer design yeah absolutely thanks for
walking us through that Lauren again the
launch escape system is armed that
protects Bob and Doug so that if
something were to go wrong they can
shoot off of the pad away from the
rocket and parachute to safety in the
ocean that is such a crucial safety
capability and so now we want to go over
to Hawthorne for an operational update
with John thanks Marie we are counting
down those final minutes everything is
still looking good on the Falcon 9 and
the dragon vehicles for an on-time
launch but weather is trending the wrong
way right now we're keeping our ears
open in case we hear that the weather is
going to be no-go for the rest of the
count right now we are counting down at
t-minus 30 to minute day to unlock
t-minus 35 minutes right on time the
propellants we use on Falcon 9 are a
fuel which is rocket grade kerosene also
called RP one of refined petroleum we
use an oxidizer and that's the super
chill liquid oxygen or LOX as we call it
those two propellants with you know come
together but they don't like so we need
an ignition source to complete the fire
triangle for this Falcon nine uses a
fluid called t tub you might see that
just before first stage ignition or
maybe later in the second stage ignition
you get a green colored flame as the t
tub comes out into the oxygen and that
ignites the main engines right before
the rocket takes off or the second stage
engine lights now currently in the
fueling rp1 fuel is about 10% full on
the first stage that's the bottom
two-thirds of the stack of the vehicle
you can see on the left the first stage
is that a long white cylinder at the
bottom plus that black cylinder called
the inter stage that's the entire first
stage that we're loading with LOX and RP
one kerosene that's the part that comes
back to earth the second stage just
above it the white cylinder and then
above that will be the dragon trunk and
the capsule now currently the second
stage is also loading fuel with RP one
that's about eight percent full right
now
we are loading liquid oxygen on the
first stage the second stage liquid
oxygen load will begin at t minus 16 and
a half minutes if the weather cooperates
so locks loading will then continue on
both the first and second stage until
the last few minutes of the countdown
helium loading is also underway in two
pressure vessels on the first second
stage we use that to pressurize the
tanks in flight as the propellant is
being pulled out by the merlin turbo
pumps dragon onboard the spacecraft you
can see the astronauts are monitoring
systems while propellant is loaded into
the Falcon nine now one way demo flight
last year and then the in-flight escape
test earlier this year the sounds inside
the Dragon capsule were recorded so as
part of the training the sounds of the
propellant loading were played back to
acclimate the crew to what they are
experiencing now I'm stopping I'm
listening to some discussion on one of
the back nets trying to track where we
are with the weather criteria we're just
passing another weather gate right now
trying to see whether or not the
conditions are go in certain situations
when the weather is no-go you have to
wait 30 minutes and we are now inside of
30 minutes but if the cloud moves away
if the conditions improve we may be able
to continue to countdown for another 14
minutes and reassess so we're waiting to
see whether or not we can continue the
count currently we are the range they're
ready to support with no problems in the
air in the C space area but again the
weather that's the one that's looking
bad and we're gonna continue to listen
and as a reminder today we have an
instantaneous launch time so at this
point if we hear a hold for any reason
we're going to have to stand down and
target our backup launch opportunity on
may 30th
for demo to Bob and Doug's flights a
station will take about 19 hours and
their journey is fairly similar to the
trip our cargo dragon makes back and
forth to the International Space Station
with two noticeable differences ducking
and splashdown as we await t-minus zero
and just a little over twenty-eight
minutes from now ground operation seems
just doing those final series of system
checks making sure both dragon and
Falcon nine are ready for liftoff and
really keeping an eye on that whether
you're just continuing to get live views
of the teams you've got Falcon 9 and
dragon on your left and that both Bob
and Doug on the right as they prepare at
the Cape for liftoff once we hit t0 and
a successful launch occurs we will watch
Falcon 9 and drag and make their ascent
until Falcon 9 and first and second
stages separate and send dragon on its
way to the space station and once it
gets on orbit mission operators will
prepare dragon for on-orbit operations
where dragon will execute a series of
burns that are gonna gradually raise its
orbit to align more closely with the
International Space Station and you're
seeing some of that track in the
animation on your screen right now
after doing enough again for a dragon
look sounds like we're gonna get a
weather update real quick for the crew
yeah we're currently just evaluating one
constraint no constraint on the field
mill rule which looks at lightning
energy dissipation we expect to have an
update at about t-minus 20
more information there and whether we
would be able to continue into the prop
load or or scrub at that time
okay gang back for the up baby
appreciate it copy soggy with some more
words in about six minutes
okay so it sounds like we're gonna die
in about six minutes if we're gonna have
enough time and John I was referring to
a couple of those weather situations
where we have to have a certain amount
of time in this case with the field
mills about 15 minutes so they have
until about 60 minutes and 30 seconds to
really make sure that we're gonna have
enough time for that to dissipate so
we're gonna be listening for that
weather update in just a couple of
minutes but it is gonna be a pretty
interesting trip uphill for them once
they actually get on orbit and a very
exciting countdown with six minutes to
figure out if we are launching today but
targeting back to what we were talking
about next we'll dragon will make its
approach and actually dock with the
space station this is a very different
process from what we've seen with dragon
cargo deliveries in the past which used
a process called birthing and birthing
requires a spacecraft to approach the
station and then stop so a crew member
can maneuver the station's robotic arm
to capture the spacecraft docking on
this version of Dragon can be done
autonomously Lucroy alien bug started
autonomously with no crew aboard the
station it's typically a faster process
both when arriving and leaving but it
does still require pinpoint accuracy to
approach safely once captured a
spacecraft thing gets attached to a
common berthing mechanism it's the same
type of port that we use to connect each
of the modules together onboard station
it's a little bit slower process than
docking but the hatches are
significantly larger than docking ports
to make them perfect for bringing up
large cargo items dragon will spend up
to 120 days dock before preparing to
return home following successful
completion of dragons test objectives
and cargo loading operations the crew
will close out the cabin perform final
system checks and configure the vehicle
for undocking once the automated
undocking sequence is complete dragon
will complete two departure burns using
its streiko engines pushing it away from
the space station
and then after dragon departs the
station it's ready for its trip home and
that'll have deorbit entry and landing
and the number number of other
operations if you're looking at this
animation it might look like we're
playing the one we played originally in
Reverse because that's kind of how it
goes but just a little bit quicker all
of the operations following the final
departure maneuver will include things
like trunk separation closing that nose
cone again executing a deorbit burn and
once they're inside the atmosphere
deploying drogue and then main
parachutes and then finally splashing
down off the Florida coast at which team
time teams will move in get Bob and Doug
up out of the water and get them out of
the capsule once they're on the boat so
we have four minutes now until we get
that next expected weather update let's
go down now to the team at Kennedy
worried alright thanks Dan if you're
just joining us we are now t-minus 23
minutes and 48 seconds from the first
launch of astronauts to the
International Space Station from US soil
in nine years we're gonna find out in
less than four minutes if the weather
looks good for that and this will mark
the beginning of a new era where more
people will be able to fly to space than
ever before in fact we took a poll a
little bit earlier to ask you if you
have the opportunity to fly to space
would you go and 86% of those of you
watching answered that you would go to
space that's an incredible number I
think you know realizing that you don't
have to be a military astronaut or a
NASA astronaut to fly in space you can
be a regular savile you know just a
regular purse and going off to space on
a spacex type rocket so I think that's
why the numbers are so high yeah and we
are really thrilled to to see all the
folks watching along online I know we
certainly hope that that this is a go
but we're again we're gonna hear a
little bit of a weather update in less
than three minutes now and Leland you
know I know they're waiting for a
weather update and they've come you know
almost all the way down the count what
do you think Bob and Doug are thinking
about right now
you know we on 120 and sts-129 we were
having some weather problems and I think
we were getting close to the countdown
and then it seemed like the sky just
cleared up right above our heads we saw
it and we knew we were going and you
know we always know that you
you can have any types of delays fuel
prop delays all kinds of things that can
happen but we've trained over and over
and over again for these types of
scenarios and so you know we want to be
safe we want to be safe for our families
and we'll you know do this another day
if it doesn't work with the weather I
love that John I always says whether
it's that thing that everybody talks
about but no one can do anything about
it and it is this interesting thing of
just you know succumbing to the mother
earth she's gonna tell us if we can go
or not today right yeah well if it
happens I mean and look at it this way
Bob and Doug got one really great
rehearsal in right it's always best to
practice and practice and practice yes
so again we're less than two minutes now
from that weather update that is going
to go directly to Bob and Doug and we
will quiet down so we can listen in for
that because I know we can't wait to
find out what that is and those of you
watching that have been following along
we are eagerly awaiting to hear whether
the weather is going to be a showstopper
today
this class can seem really deceiving at
times right you see the blue skies
peeking through and you think
everything's fine
but you just don't know so we have those
launch weather officers absolutely and I
know you know we've talked about it
before but it's not just the weather in
Florida that they're looking at they've
got to look at weather downrange if they
if they were to have an abort in flight
and they needed to come down somewhere
and the in the ocean they need to
consider what the weather's like out
there because recovery teams have to go
out and get them in a situation like
that so there's so many variables and
that's why not just with this flight but
you know with every human spaceflight
we've had in the past there's always a
very good chance of a scrub because
because you do have so much criteria
that you have to meet and we're gonna
listen in now we're just seconds away
from a weather update h2 our people
unload complete
that is liquid oxygen you see venting
off the rocket that's completely normal
and expected we're standing by for a
weather update unless you can give us
another 10 minutes I don't think we're
gonna get there with any of the rules
today thank you 10 minutes I mean
another 10 minutes pass t0o
16:45 local I think we probably clear on
all the rules but not quite not quite
gonna make it for this okay we're gonna
check back in with you about two minutes
and then I'll call it up that about uh
you my seventeen minutes okay yeah we
got wait there someone we're starting to
count down but we still have one above
two thousand so if that gets below
and that didn't sound great right there
that was the weather net going out but
we're still standing by for a final
decision
you
and we're going to continue to listen in
for an update but in the meantime we're
going to go over to John instructor at
SpaceX headquarters in California John
and Dragon SpaceX on whether we're still
t-minus 18 minutes and Karen LD is are
still expect an update from LT waiting
in about another minute for one final
check with weather
we're gonna check at 7 minutes possibly
we don't really expect that things will
have improved the weather officer was
not optimistic that the weather would
clear up that rapidly we did hear the
launch director might take Taylor joke
that you know if we could move 10 more
minutes past the t0 weather conditions
may improve but Mike was not able to do
that we have an instantaneous window
today so at 17 minutes we want to make
that call because shortly after that we
will begin loading liquid oxygen on to
the second stage
so if we're not going to have the
opportunity to launch standby you need
to violate a couple different weather
rules that now do not expect to clear in
time to love for and launched today
today's launch attempt watch out of
sequence and proceed into the launch
abort out of sequence please
font report has started
and Dragon SpaceX unfortunately we are
not going to launch today you are go for
5.10 zero launch scrub
got 1 0-0 it was a good effort by the
teams and we understand and we'll meet
you there
we've heard the call from the crew they
have been informed launch director mike
Caylor has called a scrub for the day
and we got the feedback when the dragon
team informed Bob and Doug they said we
gave it a good try what they understand
and we are here to try another day so
right now we did officially hold the
clock it looks like a team - 16 minutes
54 seconds the launch automatic sequence
that controls the Falcon 9 the loading
of propellant for the cycling of valves
that is also stopped we now proceed into
what is a normal scrub sequence for us
we practice this every launch so now we
move into safely taking the propellants
the pressurization gas is back off the
first and second stages as things begin
to a safe configuration then we will
disarm the escape system on dragon we
got down to just inside 17 minutes
spacecraft we had the fuel loading going
on we had a liquid oxygen loading going
on everything what's second stage and
the weather just needed a little bit
more time to clear the condition where
we didn't have that time because we had
a new taneous window and so with that
SpaceX launch director had to call upon
the for the safety rules that we have
for this flight so right now the team is
undergoing the post scrub operations on
both dragon as well as Falcon 9 working
with the range no issues being reported
right now as we start to go through that
sequence everything looks good and Dan
we're a we had a good webcast going here
until the very end so you know we'll
look at it is now we've had another
great dry rehearsal last Saturday we did
a dry one I should say and today we've
done a wet dress rehearsal but sorry we
just couldn't get there down yeah thanks
John I and obviously we can't control
the weather we came right down to the
wire they're hoping we could just
squeeze in between those cloud systems
get a launch today but it wasn't to be
but it doesn't mean this we're done
we're gonna have another attempt coming
up in just three days so we're gonna be
doing this all over again essentially on
Saturday on the 30th and that launch
attempt is going to be coming at 3:22
p.m. Eastern Time so a little bit
earlier in the day it's gonna look
largely the same to everything that we
saw today with the crew waking up going
through suit up making their way to the
pad so it's good if we're gonna feel a
lot of deja vu I think on Saturday but
still exciting safety is always first so
if weather was not there for us today
hopefully Saturday it will be there for
us and we will have a safe launch on
Saturday yeah the initial weather report
still had us at about I think a 40
percent possibility of violations so
weather a little bit better but we're
still gonna be kind of rolling the dice
it is Florida in the spring and summer
so storms are always a possibility one
of the good things though the vehicle
appeared to be in great health
throughout the day both dragon and
Falcon nine so we didn't have to scrub
for any technical issue we're gonna
continue and follow along with Bob and
Doug until they're out of that capsule
as again they had started loading fuel
onto the Falcon 9 rocket so they'll have
to wait until all that fuel comes off
they'll disarm the launch escape system
which still stays armed because they're
still sitting on on a partially loaded
rocket and then once they're able to
disarm that launch escape system the
crew arm will swing back out they'll
make their way once again back the way
they came and then we'll be back to crew
quarters for Bob and Doug for a few more
days
[Music]
but if you're just now tuning in
wondering why we're not still counting
down we did have a launch scrub today we
were just a little understandable along
an appeal for its are novel or upload
expecting about a 40-minute upload time
so that call out the locks the liquid
oxygen fuel pumping out of the first
stage of the Falcon nine everything
looking good with that expecting about
forty minutes for all that fuel to come
off so again once that fuel comes off
Bob and dog will be able to disarm the
launch escape system and that crew
access arm will swing back out they'll
be able to make their way back down and
then over to crew quarters so
unfortunate scrub today because of
weather that was the one thing we were
tracking from the moment we started
today watching Baba Doug get suited up
for their launch we did abort today's
launch or scrubbed today's launch with a
little under 17 minutes to go until our
t0 time which was 433 so that's gonna
move us to our next attempt which is
coming up on Saturday and that time is
going to be 322 p.m. Eastern Time so a
little bit early earlier in the day for
Bob and Doug and for everybody else
watching around the world they're still
gonna have a 19-hour flight to station
if that's when we launch and a lot of
this stuff that we saw today is going to
look very similar but we're just going
to try again cross our fingers hope for
a little bit weather better weather
and again this goes with every lunch we
do track everything all the way down to
zero to make sure that everything is go
making sure that the ranges go whether
is go so this is standard procedure we
always tend to make sure that we have a
back up day launch day in case we do ab
scrubs like today so this is this is
pretty normal and standard nothing to be
worried about again we do this for the
safety of our vehicles as well as today
we had astronauts on our vehicle so even
bigger reason for us to make sure that
we have safe weather for them to fly and
just a reminder for everyone still tuned
in it takes about 40 minutes for all of
this propellant to come off of the
Falcon 9 and while it is offloading that
launch escape system on Dragon which is
designed to pull the capsule away if
there's any issue with the rocket or
anything on the pad that is still armed
so we're gonna continue to stay with
this until all the propellants off and
then we'll see the launch escape system
get disarmed Bob and Doug will be able
to open up their visors again the launch
the crew access arm will swing back out
and link up with dragon and make their
way off and then down the tower at the
pad but if you're just now tuning in no
launch today we did have to scrub
because of weather
we're gonna be moving to our second
attempt on Saturday just a little bit
earlier in the afternoon just gonna
continue to stand by as this propellant
comes off we heard a call that
everything was going nominally or as
expected so far and then once the all
the propellants off we should see Bob
and Doug make their way out of Dragon
shortly after
[Music]
and what you're seeing on your screen is
a live view of Bob and Doug on the right
side inside of dragon as they're waiting
for propellant to be removed from the
vehicle so that it is safe for them to
disarm the launch escape system
[Music]
and this will take a bit of time so we
are going to stay alive with you to
watch this as they exit the vehicle
eventually and come down from from
standing down on launch today
up until the point of the scrub we had a
really clean countdown weren't tracking
any issues with Falcon 9 or the Dragon
spacecraft so always a good thing to see
we did have to scrub because of that
weather to be a little bit more specific
we were still in violation of one of the
weather criterias it was the strength of
electric fields in the atmosphere that
the 45th Space Wing and other weather
operators are monitoring around the
launch pad and that's one of those rules
where we need a certain amount of time
if we're in a violent 50% on stage what
Lochhead you'll 85% on stage you feel so
the propellant off load on Falcon 9
continuing to go well but we needed a
little bit more time if we were gonna be
able to clear that launch weather
constraint and since we do have an
instantaneous launch window today we
weren't able to make it so we hope for
better weather coming up on Saturday
where again our next launch attempts
gonna be at 3:22 p.m. Eastern Time and
we'll be able to go through everything I
mean we we saw them get suited up they
had a great ride out to the pad all of
their initial checks on both the suits
with pressure checks and communication
checks went well able to get the dragon
hatch closed the launch escape system
arm and Falcon 9 started its fueling
just now I'm able to make a good weather
window today and as John I said earlier
was just another great rehearsal today I
don't think you can get enough practice
doing this so when Saturday comes or
when we the day that we can actually
launch the vehicle Bob and Doug and the
NASA and SpaceX team are fully prepared
with just an extra rehearsal on the belt
now as we had talked a couple of times
throughout our countdown the weather is
a lot more complex when we're launching
humans you have some more stringent
requirements in place not only around
the pad but in the case of this launch
today we're also looking at whether the
entire asset corridor as we call it so
basically the entire way that they were
flying up the east coast of the United
States and this launch today we're
monitoring that weather because those
are areas that if they have an asset
abort or basically dragon firing off of
the Falcon 9 while they're flying into
space we have to make sure that
conditions are good in the sea states
around those areas just so they're not
going to be landing in the middle of a
hurricane which we did have a tropical
storm forming right off the coast of
South Carolina today just to help
complicate things a little bit and
people might be asking if we knew the
weather was going to be a little iffy
today where I continued to countdown
well that is the reason why we do all
these checks all the way to countdown in
Florida the weather is you know pretty
sporadic sometimes a thunderstorm or
hurricane will pass through within 20
minutes it's gone and we could have
clear skies for a safe launch so we
continued as scheduled
standard procedure again - just
continuing to continue to monitor
weather all the way down to the last
minutes of the count and we see what
happened so today unfortunately we did
scrub for weather but we will attempt
again this Saturday on May 30th
and Dan Jessi a couple of things to add
on there right now we are 11 minutes
after the scrub was called liquid oxygen
and feel they're coming off of the first
stage hard to tell from the view it's
still a little misty around the tank
because there's LOX on board but we're
between half and a third of each of the
fuel and LOX tanks filled on the first
stage so propellant coming out right
there plan the second stage fuel tank is
offloading that's going slower but it's
also a smaller tank it doesn't take very
long to your load it or to offload it
the other thing that we're working on is
the high pressure helium spheres as well
as the nitrogen spheres for the landing
leg system the pressure will be brought
down on those eventually getting it down
low enough to where people can re-enter
the pad area so right now the team is
preparing once they get up permission
the SpaceX ingress egress technician
team will come back inside the caution
area around the pad make their way up
when conditions are right open up the
hatch and assist the astronauts out of
the dragon I'd like to point out that
for those who are wondering whether or
not having gone through this putting
propellant pressurization gas is on
getting fairly close to launch weather
that has done anything to wear out the
Falcon 9 or the dragon the answer is no
if you can recall the Falcon 9 is
designed for at least 10 flights and
about time we get up to a 10th flight
will be doing testing to find that we
probably got enough margin to continue
keep flying so this is the very first
flight of a new first stage in a new
second stage so we've not we haven't
even gotten through the first flight and
in all of our margin calculations we
also take into account the fact that we
may scrub a watch so even today's
operation where we have pressurized and
we have stressed the vehicle a little
bit that's taken into account in our
design and our qualification test
the other good thing is that the most
stressing part of the flight for the
Falcon 9 on the first stage is the
re-entry so we didn't even get through
that so we're sitting here on the pad
it's a fairly straightforward situation
and not stressing on the Falcon 9 and on
the Dragon spacecraft with the human
rating factors to carry crew there is
enough factors of safety margins of
safety redundancy that just having two
people on board and closing the hatch
and even pressurizing the propellant
system does not eat into the margins of
the automatic sequences that we use
routinely both at the launch sites
Kennedy Space Center Cape Canaveral even
Vandenberg Air Force Base as well as in
our Texas test site for first and second
stage those sequences are running
propellant is coming off of the vehicle
per plan and we see Bob and Doug up in
the Dragon spacecraft just waiting when
we can get up there open the hatch and
help them egress and come on back down
the tower
and the other thought I had Dan and
Jessie is right now we are coming up
what would have been t0
and I'm wondering 10 minutes from now
whether the weather officer would turn
around and say yes it turned good you
just didn't have a long enough window we
only had one second and we needed 10
minutes so we'll have to ask offline
that say hey did the weather conditions
improve and one thing I'll tag on to
that dan was mentioning and Jessie we're
talking about the launch opportunities
the launch window does move earlier on
Saturday a little bit so it just
happened to be orbital dynamics said
today if you want to go to the
International Space Station and you want
to launch northeast which is the
approved trajectory you have to go right
at four thirty three thirty five p.m.
Eastern Daylight Saving Time you pick
another day the T zero moves it's just
luck of the draw we might have been
doing this at 8:00 in the morning when
we were getting lightning or we could
have been doing it a few hours from now
when conditions may have been acceptable
so in the end we can all look at Isaac
Newton and Johannes Kepler for orbital
dynamics telling us when do we launch
and that stuck us right in the middle of
a period of bad weather so there's my
science lesson for today damn Jesse
appreciate that job helped soften the
blow just moving past that t-minus zero
time
but for anybody if you're just now
tuning in wondering why Falcon 9 is
still sitting there on the pad as we
move past that t0 we did have a scrub
for weather today just not able to clear
all those constraints we keep a very
close eye on the weather around the pad
and their whole way I can say looks for
weather
right now Bob and Doug are still in
happy weather yeah I just wanted to give
you some more Awards on the scrub
rationale yeah so we basically scrubbed
due to three rules or violating both all
three would have been expected to clear
10 minutes after our 2-0 time and those
three were natural lightning the feud
Mills and the attached anvil
[Music]
yeah we copy J we appreciate that update
we can see some raindrops on the windows
and just figured that whatever it was
was too close to the launch pad at the
time we needed it not to be so we
appreciate that understand that
everybody's probably a little bit bummed
out it's just part of the deal everybody
was ready today and we appreciate that
and the ship looked great and we'll do
it again I think on Saturday top y'all
and yeah we concur and appreciate your
resilience sitting there in the vehicle
for us
we deaf easy job nothing better than
being prime crew on a new spaceship
[ __ ] it up
all right some some great words from Bob
and Doug they're feeling good inside
dragon they'll be ready to go when we
make our next attempt on Saturday right
now we're just still waiting for all of
the fuel to come off the Falcon 9 rocket
out of a block of fuel roughly 20% and
today to fuel 36% into that call right
there we're still at a little over 20%
on fuel our p1 and lox liquid oxygen on
the first stage and then at about 26
percent on our p1 on that second stage
so again it takes about 40 minutes once
the process starts so we should have
right around 30 minutes or so until all
that fuels off and then the crew will
get the go to disarm the launch escape
system will see that crew access arm
swing back into place and they can begin
to egress or get out of the Dragon
spacecraft
and you heard it live that weather
update of what we violated we were just
10 minutes off unfortunately but again
today was an instantaneous launch and as
John explained it's due to the orbital
mechanics and in making sure that at the
time we launched it will allow us to get
to the space station on time and
accurately so you could see on your
right screen Bob and Doug are patiently
waiting they do still have their visors
on and still strapped into their seats
the launch escape system is still armed
right now as we are offloading fuel and
will not disarm until prop offload is
complete and this is just to ensure the
safety of Bob and Doug and make sure
that they can egress safely from the
rocket
[Music]
and just a reminder today just this
first attempt we're gonna be right back
here looking like on Saturday for
attempt number two launch America's not
going anywhere
still still on the track to get Bob and
Doug into space and get this career
dragon up to the International Space
Station so it's always it's always good
if you're gonna scrub probably rather
scrub for weather than an issue on
either Falcon 9 or dragon and we weren't
tracking any issues with the flight
systems throughout our countdown today
everything passed with leak checks on
the hatches and the crew suits all the
communications working great all the
teams were ready to go so John I said
always nice to have a little bit more
practice and we'll be right back at it
on Saturday what would this launch be if
it wasn't even more exciting to try and
launch today and now we have to push
into Saturday's really got a bill yes
hey Dan and Jesse another thought
crossed my mind while I'm watching the
diagram here showing fuel is just about
off first and second stage we're down
under 10% LOX is also just about off of
it a lot shorter yep getting the
announcement cools roughly 20 page two
feels a 20% stage one LOX is under 10
percent so just continue continuing to
come off of the vehicle as expected on
the monitor
Bob and dog continue with visors down
there launch escape system is armed as
we've mentioned if there is anything
that were happen to go wrong right now
they still have the viable pad abort
means something that we demonstrated way
back in 2015 on one of these webcasts
when we fired the Dragon capsule using
the eight super Draco's off of the
launch pad and it splashed down offshore
in the Atlantic Ocean so they're staying
there with the system armed until all
the hazards that are essentially removed
and we bring the crew access arm around
them
[Music]
we're standing by a minute we're gonna
listen to launch director talking to the
weather officer
[Music]
and if you're just now tuning in we did
not launch today we did have a scrub
because of weather but if as we were
saying we are looking forward to trying
this again on Saturday our launch time
on Saturday will be another
instantaneous window so we'll have to
have the weather cooperate again now
launch time will be at 3:22 p.m. Eastern
I think of our last weather update put
us at about 40% probability of violation
John I can check me real quick yeah Dan
what I saw coming out of the air force
was 40 percent probability of violation
I believe it's always tough because they
report in terms of violation and the
optimist have to subtract that from a
hundred percent to get a 60 percent
chance I'll plan my picnic we were
listening the SpaceX launch director
Mike Taylor was talking to the launch
weather officer asking about the three
criteria that scrubbed us today it
sounds like in another minute or two the
lightning and the attached anvil cloud
rules will clear the fool still bouncing
around several more minutes before that
one would clear so we'd need even longer
than 10 minutes in the window today it
looks like for all the rules to clear it
brings up what I want to mention a
little while ago I got lost listening to
the weather brief but there are a lot of
folks are going why an instantaneous
launch window for Falcon 9 and Dragon
now typically when we go to the space
station when we do the mission planning
it's an instantaneous window
there may be enough performance in the
rocket to launch somewhere in a
five-minute period but you've got to
pick a time in there but in the case of
Falcon 9 once we start propellant load
at t-minus 35 minutes it doesn't matter
so much if you can move 5 or 10 minutes
left or right because the whole sequence
is scripted we do the flight analysis
assuming that the temperatures of the
propellants are below a certain amount
so that we know how much performance is
available to the rocket how much margin
we're gonna have so essentially if you
start the countdown you know 4 hours 8
hours out like we're doing today and you
have a very short window once you get
our propellant loading at t-minus 35
minutes you have to go as soon as you
get to 0 we don't have the ability to
stop the countdown wait 5 minutes
now sudden the liquid oxygen starts
warming up from 340 degrees below zero
in the ground system and that changes
how much performance you get carrying
into orbit and we don't want to cut into
those margins now if we had had
something like a four-hour window which
some communication satellites have we
could actually get down to almost zero
hold the count D tank the Falcon 9 wait
a while it takes us about an hour and a
half reload a whole new batch of cold
liquid oxygen and fuel from the big
storage tank that we've got there at pad
39a and try to launch again but in that
case you have to be able to launch you
know about an hour and a half or so
later after you scrub and in the case of
the international space station an hour
and a half from now it's nowhere near
where we need to be the performance of
the Falcon 9 and the dragon so today
it's a combination we start the day with
a second window window for the Falcon 9
for awareness of what the there's a
little explanation for folks who are
wondering why we have such a tight
window
and liquid oxygen is just about off of
the stage and so things are clocking
right along for the 40 minute time line
everything looks good and we'll wait to
hear that we're clear and then when we
get the call for Bob and Doug to go
ahead and disarm launch escape system
and the crew access arm will watch come
back out Center itself around the Dragon
hatch and then the ingress team will go
up there and open the hatch thank you
for the science lesson John I no charge
we did hear a quick call of the crew
there we should be just under 10 minutes
away from that prop prop offload
completing it looks like we're just
tracking complete and there we have the
confirmation stage to offloads complete
and we should have now just the RP 1 so
that densified propellant or the RP 1 is
kerosene we should be under 10% little
under 10 minutes until that's off and
then we'll step through those events we
were discussing where they'll be able to
disarm the launch escape system get the
arm back out there and Bob and Doug can
begin to exit the Dragon spacecraft
[Music]
[Music]
still not the friendliest skies in the
background that is Florida though the
weather is constantly changing over
there which is why we always have to
keep an eye on it through every single
launch that we have out there Baba Doug
are patiently waiting as you can see
that is a live view of them on the crew
Dragon vehicle as they're waiting prop
offload to complete second stage prop
offload is complete we are just waiting
on first stage to is complete
waiting on Stage one fuel roughly five
minutes or so
[Music]
and again the launch escape system is
still armed we are waiting for a prop
offload to complete before they disarm
that and then they will be able to
egress from the crew dragon vehicle we
just heard we should be just under five
minutes away from the last of that fuel
coming out of the Falcon 9 first stage
and then we'll see those events start to
pick back up and we'll see the crew arm
swing back out they've been in those
seats for a couple hours now they
typically get inside of Dragon a little
over two and a half hours ahead of
launch so they've been strapped into
these seats for quite a while
they aren't custom sized though so
there's comfortable and as snug as
possible obviously since they're going
to be in them for a really long time but
most importantly when you're doing that
splashdown at the very end of the
mission you its bay it's your car seat
and splashing down or landing on land is
not the most gentle of procedures and a
capsule so just really making sure that
they're they're snug inside of that
Dragon capsule but we should be a little
under five minutes away from the Prop
offload being completed
and as Dan mentioned those suits are
custom made but the seats are also
custom fit for each astronaut as well
they do remain on crew dragon for this
mission for almost 24 hours about so we
do want to make sure that they are
comfortable and make sure that these
suits and the the seats are comfortable
enough for them to stay in that position
for a while
I believe when they get into orbit they
are allowed to get out of their seats
and get a little bit more comfortable
but it's a long ride for them yeah once
once they do get on orbit they are able
to get out of the seats and actually out
of their suits - since for this flight
path today they was gonna take him about
19 hours so Bob and Doug will act would
actually have had about eight hours to
sleep on board the Dragon capsule so
we weren't able to launch today though
the rendezvous on Saturday should be
very similar to what we would have had
if we launched today where it'll take
him about 19 hours to get to the
International Space Station
so they'll launched and they'll have a
number of different events that we'll be
able to walk you through including
manual piloting of Dragon and just
really putting the spacecraft through
all of the paces before it arrives at
the International Space Station because
again this this is a test flight and
this is this last test before we certify
the Dragon spacecraft for regular crewed
flights which we'll just be bringing up
those long duration six-month maybe even
a year long missions right and it's it
should be a very exciting test flight
because it's pretty much like an actual
mission when Bob and Doug get on the
station they will be before performing
some research while they're up there and
performing tests and and doing some
final things for this demonstration
mission yeah but I mean just for right
now
we are just gonna continue to stay with
them until we see them come out of
Dragon because the launch escape system
still armed while we wait for this
propellant offload to complete that's
just done as a safety measure anytime
you have rocket propellants beneath you
you want to make sure that we have a
good way for them to get out of the way
and so we should be within just a couple
of minutes for that final bit of rp1
coming off the first stage and then
we'll hear the crew get that go to
disarm that launch escape system we'll
see the crew access arm swing back in
but if you're just tuning in expecting
them to be in space we did have a scrub
today due to weather our next launch
attempt is going to be this Saturday May
30th at 3:22 p.m. Eastern Time and just
like we did today we're gonna be
bringing you every single step of the
way it's gonna look a little familiar if
you watched all of today's but it's
going to be just as exciting
could imagine it might even be more
exciting with all the anticipation that
we've hyped this launch up for her with
already going through it all today but
again the more practice we have you know
the better off we will be hopefully next
launch attempt we will have a flawless
launch and actually be able to lift off
with good weather
yeah weather's going to be the big thing
that will continue to watch that was the
culprit today for our scrub and our
initial weather reports already looking
at about a 40 percent possibility of
violation probability of violation so as
John I was saying the optimist and us
have to say that's 60 percent good so
we're gonna look we're gonna look at the
good side of this and that's roughly
what we were in the days leading up to
this we won't have a rogue tropical
storm forming off of South Carolina on
us on Saturday but Florida weather will
always be dynamic so let's continue to
track and hopefully get a good chance
hit that window on Saturday and just a
reminder everything else on the vehicle
and for the mission was looking good
today it was just the weather which as
John I said earlier and Lauren even
referred to to him mentioning this
weather is the one thing that we
actually cannot control on our missions
so unfortunately it did cause us to
scrub today but the healthy the the
vehicles are healthy Bob and Doug we're
ready and they should be ready to go
again with the next launch launch
attempt on Saturday
[Music]
just looking at our data looks like that
our p1 is just about all out so we'll
just kind of stand by for a few more
moments hopefully we get that call soon
John I
yeah I was going to while we were
waiting to hear the call that the last
percentage of feel is off I was going to
comment on Jesse's discussion rod it was
just the weather I think during this
countdown there were more words said
about the weather then I'm listening
right now to whether discussion in the
background
and again for people wondering if we
knew that we did have bad weather will
no even call this morning okay we do
monitor this all the way down all the
way down to the final minutes of the
countdown and with Florida weather being
pretty sporadic sometimes we have even
hurricanes coming through or bad weather
coming through and passing 20 minutes
later and having good weather for a
launch so this is why we continued to
attempt to launch today but
unfortunately 40-0 today weather was not
on our side
yeah Jesse this John again I dropped off
to listen to a weather discussion they
were just giving the times the lightning
rule went green so we could have gone
with a lightning concern the attached
kanva were all cleared but the field
mail rule is expected to clear at 58
minutes after the hour so that's another
four and a half minutes from now so we
we were close but we needed about 25
minutes
later launch time it does remind me at
risk of offending some people but the
old saying that says it's better to be
on the ground wishing you were flying
then flying wishing you were on the
ground yes definitely safety first
always and making sure that when Bob and
Doug do fly they are flying safely and
as planned so again this is standard
procedure for us to make sure that they
do have a safe flight to the
International Space Station
[Music]
all right well for now we're just
continuing to stand by expecting the
call that all of that prop has now been
offloaded from Falcon 9 that thing
vehicle takes to all melty be set points
or Icarus
[Music]
at this moment the launch escape system
still armed once the prop offload is
complete that'll be the next step in our
procedures to have Bob and Doug begin to
make their way out of Dragon
[Music]
ll be countin 1 le we have the prompt
here for nominal crew egress okay so
we're ready for launch escape system
desire as a firm ready for launch escape
disarmed and MD copies you guys already
will ya large teams ready to go ahead
advice to crew a dragon SpaceX you copy
that discussion so with that you're go
for disarming launch escape system for
section 2 of 5.10 zero
but that market action to get there
being the launch of the equipment
alright that was the call we are waiting
for propelling off of Falcon 9 so Doug
Hurley ba bank and now going to disarm
the launch escape system on dragon and
once that's disarmed those eight super
Draco engines will be out of the mix I
think Dragon Gate Clifton have been
disarmed in human does not break copy
that we concur
and showing them confirm the launch
escape system has been disarmed and
Dragon SpaceX with that confirmation you
are go to open your visors and procedure
section three
Hey will open the visors and go to
Section three
as you heard and you can see Baba Dutt
can now open their visors and get ready
for exiting the vehicle again they kept
their visors on while the launch escape
system was armed
while prop offloading was continuing and
that is just to make sure that they are
safe now that there is no more prop
propellant on any of the vehicles they
are safe to have disarmed the launch
escape system and now are getting ready
for that crew arm to swing back the
hatch to open and for them to egress vex
dragon with an update for holding in
three decimal four and we're ready for
speaker rotation when you are copy that
we'll wait for the closeout team to open
the hatch and verify clearance and then
we can execute see rotation
captain
and there's that crew arm swinging back
towards dragon once that crew arm is in
place they will be able to open the
hatch on crew dragon bobbing Doug's
seats will rotate back out of launch
position so that they can safely get out
of their seats and egress the vehicle
and we heard they'll have what they
called nominal egress so just the normal
procedures for getting them out of the
capsule that means the the same closeout
team that was there to get them in we'll
be able to assist as they come out
they'll arrive and get that hatch open
then they'll be able to rotate the seats
that will rotate Bob and Doug pretty
much forward where they'll be in the
original position that the seats were
configured when they made their way into
drag and it just gets them a little bit
out and under the displays and makes
getting in and out of the capsule a
little bit easier they've been in those
seats for about three hours at this
point so definitely a long day for the
crew as they woke up about six hours
prior to our t-minus zero had their
breakfast which we confirmed with steak
and eggs please for Doug curly and then
they proceeded through all of the suit
up and the truck the trip to the pad
making their way inside dragon where
they've been for about the last three
hours at this point we were on track for
an on-time liftoff right at 4:30 3:00
p.m. Eastern Time
but did have to scrub a little under 17
minutes before launch due to weather so
for now we've offloaded all of the
propellant off of Falcon 9 the launch
escape system has been disarmed at Kerr
access arm is back right up next to
dragon as you can see in that view on
the left pretty soon we'll see the
team's arrived to get the hatch open get
Bob and Doug out they'll make their way
back to crew quarters and their
quarantine it is important to note that
throughout the entire process of them
getting into Dragon suiting up all of
those different steps they maintain that
same quarantine that they've been in
since for about two weeks now and that
is specifically for events like today
where we have to scrub and just go to
another day so we don't want to we don't
want to break that quarantine once we're
putting them into that launch vehicle
and that's a standard quarantine that we
have for any crew members flying to the
International Space Station the current
kovat 19 pandemic obviously puts a
little bit of extra pressure and a
little bit of an extra spotlight on that
but they're following a lot of the same
procedures that we have in place just to
keep crewmembers healthy before they go
and spend several months in space in an
enclosed environment with just a couple
of other people right and it's a little
bit more difficult to get them help on
the space station right so we want to
make sure that they when they do head up
to the space station that they are fully
healthy so this again is standard
procedure not just because of this
pandemic that's going on this is a
standard procedure for astronauts to
quarantine prior to heading to the
station
[Music]
and as Dan mentioned this is a standard
procedure to exit the vehicle as well we
did scrub today but this is not an
emergency State this is standard
procedure this is something that is
practiced and rehearsed and made sure
that we do follow our standard
procedures to make sure that everything
is still safe Bob and Doug exit safely
and go back into quarantine and get
ready for our next launch attempt looks
like they got a chance to stretch their
legs though yeah yes yeah I'm monitoring
along in the scrub procedure right now
they're getting the goes to get the
folks back to the pad the crew that will
open the hatch so they have notified the
team chief launch engineering to return
to the pad as a reminder around the pad
the Air Force sets up Air Force NASA set
up roadblocks to make sure nobody gets
into the hazard area so they will head
to the roadblocks they'll pull them open
so that they can drive to the parents so
launch director I think his estimating
is still about 15 minutes for the crew
to drive all the way down out to 39 a
get up the tower and then begin
operations on the hatch they have
confirmed that the purge of the dragon
service section which is nitrogen during
the countdown to avoid you know an
oxygen leak that is back on air now the
crew access arm is on air so they're
ready for the the
egress team to get up into the tower but
it's going to take them a little bit
still I think to drive down the road in
the vehicles and go up the elevator
but everything continuing to run poor
per a normal scrub countdown which we
have had the opportunity to practice
with the crew in for example the dry
dress rehearsal last Saturday after we
had done the static fire the Falcon 9
the day before
and I've been seeing a few questions
people asking why aren't we just trying
to launch tomorrow as John I was talking
us through there's some very specific
times you have to identify when you're
gonna be able to link up with the
International Space Station you only
have so much fuel which can only
generate so much energy to make sure
you're gonna intersect with the station
which is flying at over 17,000 miles an
hour so you're hitting one bullet with
another bullet some of our other launch
attempts are able to make it station but
have much longer drag to prevent us from
losing comms we're going to be switching
to umbilical at this time I'm going to
be unmerge encountered on but we'll keep
you updated here on director ground
okay yeah with you the feeder that got
down with a little over three minutes
will stand by for your next call an
umbilical the crew getting a call
they're just gonna reconfigure some
communications but as to why we're not
launching say tomorrow in corn count on
one Luke's are merged
but when we pick our launch attempts we
also have to take in mind some of the
human factors of these attempts some of
these other launch attempts may exist
but it would require dragon taking in
excess of 30 or more hours potentially
to reach the station which could wreak
some havoc with the sleep shift cycles
not only for Bob and Doug but also for
the crew onboard station that has to
line up their sleep schedule with Bob
and Doug as they arrive and the crews on
station and Bob and Doug will be
operating off of Greenwich Mean Time
once they get there dragon SpaceX comm
check umbilical Beck dragon loud and
clear on umbilical huh I'll be heavy the
same still getting good combi tween the
crew and the core here on Hawthorne but
really just to sum it up we pick our
launch attempts for a number of reasons
not just can we make it to the station
but just how long is it gonna take to
get there and that's why Saturday is
going to be our best option we're gonna
be targeting that one at 3:22 p.m.
Eastern Time for our next attempt and
it'll be a little over 19 maybe a little
over 20 hours until we actually arrive
at the space station if we're able to
get off the ground on Saturday
and then this gives Bob and Doug you
know a few days to kind of shake off the
nerves from today's launch attempt give
them some some more time to rest and
again get ready for our launch attempt
on Saturday
[Music]
[Music]
and if you're just now joining us we did
scrub our demonstration - mission today
and as John mentioned we are waiting for
the egress team to make it back to the
launch pad head up the tower and help
the crew or help Bob and Doug egress the
vehicle
[Music]
dragon space x4 closeout team status go
ahead yeah the close all team has
arrived at the pad and they are
proceeding to the white room you heard
that call out the egress team is at the
pad and are proceeding to meet Bob and
Doug in the white room where they can
open the hatch and help them exit the
vehicle
[Music]
but we'll continue to stick with Bob and
Doug until we see that hatch get open
and them start to make their way out and
then they're going to and there we can
get some views once more back at the pad
you can see that egress team moving back
in they were wearing the black clean
suits that we saw was they were helping
Bob and Doug get into the dragon just
several hours ago they're not gonna get
on the elevator make their way back up
down the crew access arm and then we'll
get that dragon side hatch opened
and as we saw earlier this is a very
tall structure but that elevator is
pretty quick there so we saw them enter
the bottom of the tower it should be a
very short time before they make it to
the top and are able to get to the white
room and open the hatch for Bob and Doug
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you are
and should just be a few more moments
will see that closeout team make their
way back into the crew access arm and
down the hatch way and again if you are
just now tuning in we did have that
scrub just about a little under 17
minutes before launch our next launch
attempt is going to be this Saturday May
30th at launch time it's going to be
another instantaneous launch time it's
going to be 322 p.m. Eastern Time over
there in Florida
assuming an on-time launch it'll be a
pretty similar flight that we were
looking at today where it'll be roughly
about 19 hours before they make that
initial contact to the International
Space Station they'll get on orbit and
execute a series of five different burns
to gradually raise their orbit until
they're just a few hundred meters below
the station and maybe a few kilometers
behind and then they'll do all of the
final approach initiation maneuvers and
by that point the team here in Hawthorne
will be working very closely with the
team down in Houston and the
International Space Station flight
control room weather for Saturday still
not ideal but it's roughly what we
started out with today where we have
about a 40% chance of possibility of
violation and it will be tracking a lot
of the same issues with cumulus clouds
and potential precipitation we'll also
be keeping an eye on all of the
downrange weather it looks like we're
seeing some people start to make their
way into the crew access arm now so we
should see them get that dragon side
hatch open in just a few minutes but as
a reminder we'll be looking at weather
around the launch pad and whether
downrange in their their flight path on
the way to orbit and that's always
checked just in case they have to do any
kind of emergency maneuver and land down
in the Atlantic Ocean we will be making
sure that the weather is it acceptable
levels all the way until they're into
space so you can see the team coming
down now should see the hatch open
momentarily and then we can begin to get
Bob and Doug out of the Dragon
spacecraft
and again we are staying live until Bob
and Doug are safely out of crew dragon
you can see on your left hand screen the
team getting ready to open the hatch for
them and help them out of their seats
and at this point the launch escape
system has been disarmed that was done
after we successfully offloaded all of
the propellants from the first and
second stage of the Falcon 9 rocket
there our propellants loaded in a dragon
so the teams looked like they were just
doing what we call kind of a sniff test
so using a portable detector just to
assess the atmosphere around the dragon
that capsule itself before they get the
hatch open and bring Bob and Doug out
all of this is standard safety
procedures for egressing the vehicle
this is to ensure the safety of the crew
as well as Bob and Doug Dragon's SpaceX
for status and the closeout team is at
the white room
they are configuring the crew arm for
egress expected to take no earlier than
10 minutes okay thank you
there should be just about 10 minutes as
a reminder there in the white room we
walk through that a little bit earlier
in our coverage this morning
the white room name simply because of
its color and that's something that
started all the way back during earlier
Gemini missions and that is literally
the last place on planet earth where
astronauts are standing before they get
loaded into this vehicle it has an
environmental control apparatus and a
seal that it can put right up against
the Dragon spacecraft just to keep all
of that dust dirt Florida humidity
dragon II chefs we're right at three
hours and see rotation I just wanted to
check in with you on comfort levels
I'd say no changes day it hasn't been
too bad at all Tokyo and obviously at
this point with the launch escape system
disarms we have loosened up straps and
got her feet out of the straps on the
bottom of its seats a little more
comfortable anyway hope y'all looks
comfortable
[Music]
[Music]
right now the closeout team just gonna
take a couple of minutes to configure
the white room they'll set up a seal
between it and the Dragon spacecraft
just to make sure we're not letting
anything from the surrounding
environment get into that spacecraft
which is kept very pristine obviously
for the crew members once they're inside
I will also they have a small bridge
that just connects the crew arm to the
capsule itself just making sure they
have a nice clear path for their
entrance and exit from the spacecraft so
should just be a few more minutes we'll
see that hatch get opened and then our
crew members can start to make their way
out and you heard seat rotation they
rotate the seats prior to their actual
flight to where they're a little bit
more parallel to the ground and that
just puts them directly in front of
those displays will see them rotate down
just giving them easy access to get out
of the capsule
and as Dan mentioned we want to keep
Fahd out of the capsule Fahd is for an
object debris so that's basically
anything that does not belong inside of
the vehicle so not just like dirt and
dust but just anything that was not
meant to be inside of there should not
be there so we're doing everything as a
standard procedure to make sure that we
do keep thawed out especially since this
is going to be another attempt and
another opportunity for Fahd to enter
the vehicle we as they're exiting we
still make sure that we keep everything
basically like a cleanroom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dragon SpaceX you may hear some vehicle
venting and about times
[Music]
Jonah's burger here with the webcast
desk in Hawthorne and California we are
continuing to wait for the crew to open
the side hatch we've got the camera
showing a schnapps dark early Bob
Behnken inside visors are up they've
gotten their feet out of the restraints
gloves are off in case of Doug it looks
like and the team is just outside the
hatch they're going through the sequence
right now make sure pressure checks are
all good make sure there are no concerns
with gases be it the propellants of the
vehicle or just nitrogen gas that we use
as a purge currently we are coming up on
about 50 minutes after the plan t0 to
just reiterate what Dan and Jesse have
been talking about earlier we had a good
countdown I had a lot of fun saying
there were no issues on Falcon 9 or
dragon of a technical sort the range was
ready to support the downrange weather
looked good in case dragon had to make a
unplanned abort splashdown in an escape
maneuver somewhere in the Atlantic and
we even had the once we get on orbit in
case dragon had to reenter and come back
early the weather was good in the
Pacific in case it had to come down so
everything was looking our way they
accept Mother Nature the weather it's
Florida and we got into the backend of
the tropical storm that has now gone
ashore and the Carolinas but
unfortunately that left everything
disrupted just enough
where we violated several the weather
rules and we did not have enough time
for them to go green green meaning where
the rain says conditions are clear and
you are all right to launch we were
still read on those rules and that was
the end of the countdown for the day
again we scrubbed at t-minus 16 minutes
54 seconds that was shortly before we
were due to begin loading the liquid
oxygen on to the second stage that was
both the logical breakpoint in the
countdown procedure where we could take
a scrub without loading one more
propellant on the vehicle and at the
same time that was when the range gave
us the final bad news that we weren't
going to get green conditions before the
clock ran out of t0 so continuing to
watch right now is the crew works to get
the hatch open
they send final commands making sure
that everything's go once the hatch is
open the ground crew can verify that
there is nothing in the way under the
seats that duck and Bob are sitting in
and we will get the seat rotation again
get them back a little bit more vertical
they're more on their backs right now in
the launch position so they'll rotate
then they'll help them out of the seats
and they'll come back out and down the
arm and off of the tower
Dragons SpaceX for status
it looks like the close all team is
inflating the hatch the arm CEO right
now
you
you
all right we've been quiet for a few
minutes but if you're just now tuning in
we did not launch today we did have to
scrub today's mission due to weather we
were just under 17 minutes away from our
t zero time at 433 Eastern when the call
was made we were still in violation of a
few of the weather constraints that just
are really there to inform teams when
it's safe to launch so we're looking at
weather both around the pad and weather
all the way on the way to orbit for them
so we did have to scrub since then we've
been able to get all of the propellant
off of Falcon 9 the launch escape system
has been disarmed and right now the
closeout teams are there in the white
room so right at the end of that crew
access arm they're configuring the big
seal that goes around the Dragon capsule
just to make sure its environment is
isolated from all that nasty Florida
weather and then they'll be able to get
the hatch open and we'll get Bob and
Doug back out
we're coming up on just under an hour
since the plan t0 again if you're just
joining us well we've been here summing
up for a while standby first - chuckles
all teams still working to do the hatch
to inflation expect another five to ten
minutes okay
we scrubbed at t-minus 16 minutes 54
seconds we violated three weather rules
the weather rules finally cleared up but
it was long after the plan t0 the SpaceX
egress team did return to the pad they
were sent through the roadblocks that
surround the pad demarcating where the
hazard areas teams up on the crew arm
and as you just heard spacex talking -
knots Bob and Doug they're working the
seal around Dragon then we make sure
that Dragon capsule pressure is
equalized with the crew arm and then
we'll go into the hatch opening sequence
so we've still got several more minutes
we'll carry that as we go a couple of
points to bring up once the crew comes
off of the dragon and comes back down
goes back to the crew quarters to D suit
we will be SpaceX for awareness we're
going to command the vehicle into a
patch open in preparation for a hatch
opening okay that's good that'll get
them into the sequence to make sure that
the pressures inside and outside note
this will equalize cabin pressure so you
may notice something there okay thanks
so as I started to mention once
everybody's off we'll leave the Falcon 9
dragon the career arm where they are
that is in the launch support position
there's no plan to come back down to
horizontal the vehicle is designed to
stay vertical now if we were to find
something wrong during the countdown as
we go through data review that could
mean that we have to come horizontal as
we did late last night early this
morning as we're working at ground issue
on the transporter director and then we
went right back up but currently no
plans to come horizontal will stay
vertical up to the next launch attempt
on Saturday there will also be as is
typical engineers will go through all of
the data they collected today and then
there will be a report out in what's
called a Delta launch readiness review
probably this Friday before we get into
the next launch attempt on Saturday
that's where the engineering disciplines
will brief management a chief engineer
launch director mission director the
nasa customer where we stand on today's
countdown what we learned as well as our
readiness to proceed into another
countdown attempt but currently at
Kennedy Space Center at historic pad 39a
we're getting ready for the hatch
opening and the crew to be able to leave
drag and come back down get out of their
suits and wait to go another day
hopefully this coming Saturday the 30th
and Dragon SpaceX sure you see vehicles
in panitch open the a Vivi's are now
open and that nitrox injection is
complete yep we felt it and heard it and
and Dragons SpaceX for status the close
our team is working is stepping into a
hatch opening up
Jonah's burger back here at the libcast
s in Hawthorne California we've got
another camera up and you can see the
side-by-side view on the monitor
astronauts Bob and Doug inside waiting
for the hatch to come open we're still
in the middle of the equalization step
make sure that pressure inside the
dragon is equal to the external the
ambient pressure so that when we open
the hatch it just comes open without any
extra force you can also see the SpaceX
team is up alongside the capsule they
are removing essentially the thermal
protection devices now for example if
you have a door handle on your
automobile if you're going to have to
re-enter from outer space you're gonna
have to put a small heat shield over
that door handle otherwise any kind of
protrude rinses cavities could be
subject to burn up so they have to take
their time make sure that we get all of
the thermal protection safety devices
off so if they can then get access to
the mechanism to go ahead and bring the
hatch open so what you're watching what
you are watching right now on the left
monitor is the egress team going through
the steps this is typical we're not
hearing any chatter over the pad net
that they're having any problems they
just take their time and make sure that
everybody's ready to bring the hatch
open when they finally get there so
currently we are t plus one hour and 11
minutes or so since the planned launch
obviously we're still on the ground as
we're going through the post scrub
operations to bring astronauts Doug
Hurley and Bob bacon out of the capsule
and you can see now H is coming open
there's a view from the camera inside
the capsule
you can see the hatch area crew gave a
quick wave to the ground crew when it
came open and right now they should be
inspecting the area underneath the seats
so that we can command the seats to
rotate back into the ingress egress
position make it a little easier on Bob
and Doug to get in and out of the seats
dragon SpaceX just for awareness they
have a few more steps in their procedure
and they should be calling to us for
seat rotation shortly okay copy that
yep we see them working on that and this
is a lead into that we are ready for the
seat rotation how does this let us know
when you're ready to serve
here the confirmation from the dragon
team talking to the astronauts that they
are just about ready to send the seat
rotation command again the ground crew
is verifying making sure that none of
the cargo that's packed in dragon
underneath the crew nothing is what is
in the way nothing came loose you're
looking at one row of crew seating but
there is you know as we've mentioned
before dragon designed to carry up to
seven but on this flight for example
much of the cargo that we're carrying is
loaded in various areas down below where
the astronauts are seated so they're
just verifying nothing's in the way so
that when they'd send the rotation
command the seats all pivot without
encumbrance
Dragons SpaceX we are initiating sea
rotation dragon copies were anyone
that call-out from the drug incor up to
the crew letting them know that we are
sending commands from the ground to
rotate the seats and you can see
astronauts Doug Hurley Bob Behnken
rotating in their seat back to a more
comfortable position to get in and out
of the capsule
your dragon SpaceX seats are upright
thanks for the failing effort today
helping us test our scrub timeline and
we'll see you saturday yeah we
appreciate those words everybody did
great today it was a great practice and
we'll do it again on Saturday everybody
has a phone we'll talk down a loop
likewise well Dan we've heard it
they've got rotated the hatch is open
the ground crew is going to work to get
the astronauts out the spacex dragon
team like the SpaceX Falcon 9 team is
going to be coming off a council now as
we turn it over to the folks on the pad
so while we didn't launch it was a
pretty good countdown and scrub sequence
so we've got that good lesson learned
under our belt and we look forward to
Saturday having even better results when
we get close to t0 that's right always
great when we don't have any issues with
the capsule or the rocket which we
didn't today just had to fight that
weather and we'll be doing the same on
Saturday we are looking at about a 50%
probability of violation that's about
wherever we were today we did see it was
all just a matter of trying to line up
correctly and didn't make it today but
we're gonna try to get out Saturday
right and it sounds like we were just
about half an hour away from making the
launch attempt today with weather with
50 percent weather chance on Saturday
hopefully we have a better day at t0 for
liftoff but we're definitely gonna all
be back Jesse myself and John I will be
here in Hawthorne to take you along
every step of the way we hope everyone
else Tunes in also because this is
really gonna be a monumental moment
we're now gonna look towards Saturday
for America once again launching US
astronauts on American Rockets from
American soil with them getting out of
the capsule though that's gonna do it
for us here at Hawthorne we're gonna
send you back down to Florida for one
last check in with our teams there so
over to you Marie Laure
Leland if you're still sticking around
and we're gonna be looking forward to
Saturday all right thanks a lot Danielle
we just were just all sitting here we
watched Bob Behnken just climb out of a
seat looks like he is out of crew Dragon
now and Doug Hurley following suit no
pun intended
there we see Bob in the foreground and
Doug climbing out of crew dragon in the
background pad closeout team looks like
helping them out so any minute they're
gonna be basically just reversing course
coming back the way from whence they
came Leland I know you had a scrub years
back yeah Marie in 2008 we were having
breakfast and I never I never scrubbed
while I was in the vehicle but we were
having breakfast and we got a call from
the from the flight director saying that
two of the we had a these engine cutoff
sensors that were bad too were bad and
the flight will say that you should have
to have three of four to fly and so we
all said we're not going to fly unless
we have them and I think we all need to
know that the flight rules are there to
protect you know our astronauts and
their families and and you know we got
very close today you know we sometimes
get that launch fever that we want to go
ahead and destroy it anyway but we we
have these rules for a reason and it's
really important to stick to the rules
even in the heat of battle even with you
know dignitaries here it's just you know
the way that we have to do it as
operators that's a good wet dress
exercise you know went through exercise
all the systems nearly 2 t0 which is
incredible I believe this may have been
the first time Bob and Doug are sitting
on top of our in our vehicle with a fuel
rocket so that's pretty cool for sure
closing the hatch exercising the
environmental life-support systems doing
that flight leak check I mean all of
this is a ton of learning that that came
out of here even if we didn't ultimately
go to space today
absolutely so we're getting a cool view
that we wouldn't have seen if they
launched they're making their way back
down the crew access arm and they are
going to be turning the corner they're
heading to the stairs that are going to
take them down to the elevator passing
the worm so yep they're heading down the
stairs now it's going to take them down
to the 255 foot level and then they're
going to be getting in the elevator take
them down to the ground level and we'll
do it again on Saturday it's actually
very reassuring that all systems were go
you know there was no problems with the
vehicle at all as Lauren as you said and
it was just some weather and I think if
we have that same performance on
Saturday and the weather gods give us
some give us some good juju there we'll
be good to go yes yes please I mean we
were we were so close today hurt my
heart if we had 10 more minutes it
sounded like we would have we probably
would have made it but I just was not
was not to be today and of course we're
gonna always do what is the safest thing
for the crew and as they head into the
elevator there we do want to go over to
operations and support building two now
where the NASA Administrator Jim
bridenstine is standing by he would like
to provide his own thoughts now we'll go
to him well thank you Marie I know
there's a lot of disappointment today
the weather got us but I also want to
say this was really it was a great day
for NASA it was a great day for SpaceX I
think our team's worked together in a
really impressive way making good
decisions all along so here in this
particular case we had just simply too
much electricity in the atmosphere there
wasn't really a lightning storm or
anything like that but there was a
concern that if we did launch it could
actually trigger lightning and so we
made the right decision we had the
parameters set ahead of time the teams
work together and in the end the right
decision was made I will tell you I've
done a lot of interviews over the last
two days and in those
I get asked over and over again is there
undue pressure here people say to me
with all of the attention of the world
on this launch with all of the VIPs
coming are you gonna feel pressure on
this launch and I will tell you i I've
told you know our teams under no
circumstances should anybody feel
pressure if we are not ready to go we
simply do not go and I will tell you I
am proud so proud of our teams working
together to make the right decision in
this particular case we have a lot to
look forward to in just a few short days
on Saturday Saturday afternoon we're
gonna do it again
here's what we know we are gonna launch
American astronauts on American Rockets
from American soil we're gonna do that
we're very close I also want to say that
this was an important milestone just
today we did a wet dress rehearsal we
haven't done a wet dress rehearsal with
our astronauts full gear before we've
done a dry dress rehearsal now we've
done a dress a wet dress so we learn a
lot every time we do these things this
is no different and we get a lot of
great data from from doing what we just
did so today was a good day
for NASA it was a good day for for
SpaceX and we've got a lot to look
forward to so I want to say
congratulations to both of the teams and
let's go let's go get this done I know
we're up for it
Saturday's gonna be a great day and here
we go again so thank you to everybody
for all the great work Murray back to
you all right thank you so much
those were some great insights from Jim
bridenstine the NASA Administrator the
crews making their way back to astronaut
crew quarters where they're going to
remain in quarantine until Saturday
they've been in quarantine for two weeks
and there they will stay to keep them
safe and healthy for our next launch
attempt again we had to stand down from
launch today because of unfavorable
weather conditions around launch complex
39a but we're gonna be ready to do this
again Saturday May 30th the new launch
time will be 322 p.m.
and our coverage will begin live here on
NASA TV at 11 o'clock in the morning
Eastern Time Saturday so be sure to tune
back in on NASA television and nasa.gov
/live if you're watching it along online
and we will be back here to take you
through it every step of the way
thanks for sticking with us and we will
see you back here Saturday